hey what's up guys my name is channel
something a little bit different for you
here today so a couple days ago i did a
live stream over on twitter tv slash the
channel i've been trying to stream more
often so uh
give that one a follow or subscribe if
you've got amazon prime now i know that
of course not everyone has the ability
to just sit down and watch a live stream
as it's happening and even if you do go
back and watch over the twitch vods
sometimes it can be difficult because
they go on for hours so what i thought
i'd do is take out some of the more
useful parts of my live streams things
that i think could be useful for
other people and post them here on this
channel so this kind of clip i mean it
feels weird to call it a clip because
it's like
40 something minutes long but this kind
of section of the live stream from a
couple days ago was about me diagnosing
some performance issues that i was
having inside hazel to be honest it's a
little bit like watching a bit of a
movie trying to figure out what on earth
was going on here so i hope that you
guys do enjoy this one let me know what
you think of this kind of content and i
will see you guys next time goodbye
what i wanna what i wanna take a look at
here
is um a bit of a performance issue and
i'm not sure why it happens
but basically when we shoot and we hit
the first time we do this right so the
current setup we have is that we fire a
projectile it's like a little
a glowing green cube
when it hits something
it destroys itself and spawns this kind
of explosion of orange spheres
but the first time this happens there's
like a couple frames where it just drops
right so there's a bit of a delay it
takes a long time
but then
it's fine on subsequent attempts so i'm
in release mode here by the way but if i
click to fire hey you can see that pause
there it's probably like a 100
millisecond pause or something like that
maybe a bit less um and these will stay
around forever but then now if i fire
again
there's no pause
right and i can keep firing and
obviously you can see it's not dropping
frames and everything is like pretty
fine right
so and they'll never just they'll never
disappear at the moment but for some
reason the first time i do this
you can see that pause right and then
subsequent times it's totally fine right
so why is this happening
not sure
um
let's let's investigate let's take a
look at it now i know that at the moment
what's happening is that when you
initiate as i i already kind of know
maybe what it is i think it's the fact
that
it has to initialize the script for that
sphere but the sphere no hang on the
sphere doesn't have a script though
so what i did was um
this actual prefab right
what is it explosive particle 2
this doesn't actually have a script
attached to it
so what it's got is it's got a mesh a
point light a rigid body and a box
collider a box collider it's a sphere
that's weird
let's um maybe we should add a sphere
collider to it
yeah
do we actually do we render we render
physics stuff right
yeah so okay so that's what the collider
looks like at the moment let me just
hide those icons so the light's not in
the way this is what it looks like
um so maybe let's remove that and let's
add a sphere collider
okay you can see it in green uh we've
got a sphere collider now and that looks
better so let's um
maybe go back to our prefabs and
drag in this we'll call explosive
particle three
uh explosive particle
three oh we've already got ep3 i wonder
what the difference is ep3
it's also a box collider
yeah whatever
um so explosive particle three is what
we're up to
yeah this is unfortunate because our
current prefab editing situation is
non-existent so we'll drag in p1 uh
where is it here
let's drag in explosive particle 3 now
so that's the prefab reference and we'll
call this
p3
uh and now i will delete literally
everything else so let's delete maybe p1
ep3
explosive particle two
p3 is a good one right guys okay this
one
this one i hope i haven't deleted
anything good p3 back into here
control s and now
now should be the same but we should
have a sphere collider yeah so we still
see that pause
oh but i didn't lock the
transform was that bad
ah sorry i didn't lock the rotation
whatever i don't care so yeah so we've
got that let's um hide the physics
colliders
okay so
no we don't have any anti-aliasing of
any kind at the moment so yes jaggi is a
jagged
um we'll probably add in like fxaa or
something um i don't really care too
much about it like at the moment i'd
rather spend my time elsewhere so i'm
not gonna do anything temporal just yet
in the future probably
and msaa and stuff is decent but it it
it will it'll slow down stuff in the
pipeline obviously because we'll have to
multi-sample
um so fxaa is probably what i'll use uh
just because it's really simple and it's
quite quick it's just one pass and
that's it
um okay so
yeah so so it's interesting because
again there is nothing
there's nothing going on from a script
point of view that's what i thought
could be it
but i know that nothing like like what
what is that pause right
because nothing should be
yeah nothing should be there okay so
let's close so this is how we're gonna
debug it right we're gonna close this
then we're going to uh come over here
and i'm gonna find some stuff that we
can take a look at
so i have um
we're going to use the
profile that we use which is called
optic
we're going to hook that up if i can
find um
is it in gui or is it build build no
uh gui
bin release
yeah there it is okay so let's uh let's
send that to the desktop because i like
to keep that around we can run it as
administrator if we want
uh we're not running hazel as
administrator but no big deal i don't
think i need that
and then what i'm gonna do is uh i am
going to hit play
and then i'm gonna go into optic i'm
gonna hit a record
and then i'm gonna fire
and then i'm gonna go back and hit
stop
okay so what we should be able to see in
optic is a massive frame 268
milliseconds and it was all inside c
sharps on update function so the
projectile on update function took a a
lot of time 261 milliseconds right so
that's clearly the uh the pause that
happens here now
is it the actual c sharp code i probably
doubt it
um i don't think it's that i think that
it's most likely
something else that it's calling so
i mean it's doing a few things
it's doing create entity here
and it's doing
create entity with id so this is the
prefab instantiation stuff but there's
clearly a lot of stuff that it does that
is not pro not instrumented so i
actually want to instrument it again we
don't really have to
if we were super cool and we are pretty
cool actually we are cool so let's take
a look at this i could just
get the sampling side of optic to
actually take a look at it so if we go
into
where am i um if i go into let's just uh
i think is dev master working yeah it is
okay so if i go into
um
bin release hazelnut
yeah so we'll run
uh it's not gonna work is it let's
create a shortcut
um let's set the working directory
to be
hazelnut
actually it might must might set its or
anything but whatever we'll run it as a
as administrator
um and we should be able to get the
sampling side of things to work
so let's clear all this data hit play
uh did that even work connection failed
play again
yep
stop 40 megabytes i think this is
definitely a bit more data
now
uh yes there is more data let's find the
long frame here it is 273 milliseconds
we had some long frames here
i'm not sure why
synchronization stuff maybe but anyway
uh this is it now we didn't get any more
data okay we'll have to instrument it
unless
no this is nothing
where's the um
what is it the syscalls no the flame
graph the flame graph
um well there it is on update entity
call method
whoa
do it to string minimal
unresolved and then some other stuff so
the flame graph is kind of helpful as
well
because it shows some stuff
but yeah script oh and then hazel call
method what's hazel call method
interesting
yeah that's fine
hmm
get asset instantiate with translation
1.5 well yeah it shouldn't this is all
very very fast so
what is it that is being so annoying huh
okay let's close that let's go back and
let's actually see what that prefab
function is doing right
so if we look at uh
[Music]
projectile which i think is it so on
update so this is what happens right and
obviously it happens on destroy so what
we do is we instantiate 10 different
particles this is what i was doing on on
the live stream two days ago
um
uh so something here ah could it be this
add force function
well okay so there's a few parts here
first of all instantiate is a thing
right this will actually create a new
entity
then we have add four and again the
thing that is almost like the thing that
is kind of suspicious here right is that
it's
not not that it's suspicious i should
say i guess
where where's my stuff man threads um is
that it's actually the projectile
function that's taking a quarter of a
second right it's not like some other
thing if it was in physics or if it was
in somewhere else we would know it's
directly
like a
it's a it's a synchronous call
it's always hard to say asynchronous
because it sounds like you're saying
asynchronous but no it's a it's a
synchronous
call
coming from
this exact function right so it has to
be something here
now
again i think that
um there's console output well the
console outputs
it's just this i don't think that's the
slow part right
we are trying to load an invalid physics
material mm-hmm
so loading invalid entities might be
not optimal
um also on physics update is failing
there are some things here that are but
that that i think is just happening all
the time that should be fine nothing
should be that slow consoles are slow
but they're not that they're not 266
milliseconds for 10 lines slow
um so i don't think it's the console i
mean look we can obviously compile that
out and i i guess we should just to
simplify this but i'm pretty sure that
it's um gonna be like either instantiate
or add force or
destroy but
destroy
this is only happening for one entity
but we are initializing we are creating
10 of these but again guys don't forget
that it's happening the first time
so again it does make me think that it's
trying to access a resource or like uh
like it's trying to load an asset or
something like that
um possibly but let's take a look at
this so instantiate so i want to add
instrumentation to some more stuff so if
we go into cncp
we have this instantiate function it's
not instrumented at all i don't know why
i guess i just had didn't go get around
to it actually a lot of stuff here as an
instrument so we have this hd profile
function
uh define right which will which we use
for instrumentation so actually pretty
much everything should be uh
instrumented right so we'll we'll leave
profile funk here copy component could
be interesting
maybe we should do that we'll profile
this just because if there's a component
who has a copy constructor that's taking
a long time which
come to think of it we did add quite a
lot of data into script component which
wasn't there in the previous version of
hazel so that's possible that's possible
that that's causing the
the issue but create prefab entity
instantiate i want this stuff profiled
uh you know find entity by tag sure all
of this stuff really should be
instrumented um
so uh like let's add this stuff in
uh and obviously like you know
this is uh only used if profiling is
turned on
so we don't we don't necessarily need to
run
uh hazel yeah there's so many new
functions um
that have been added that okay that's
that's probably good so so let's try
this let's try this again
and yeah we don't need to rely on
sampling i think for this
might even turn that off
i'll leave it
is it possible to step through the
script no um i can't at the moment we
haven't actually uh we can't connect the
debugger maybe that's something peter
wants to take a look at he does like
looking at stuff
um
[Music]
hey
okay i sent peter a message we'll see if
he can do that at some point
um all right so
why do you prefer macros instead of
verity const expression template
functions i don't know what you're
talking about so
uh i have i have both um
and i use both so yeah
anyway uh so
let's i guess we'll do the same test
again now that we have a bit more
data and we'll see if um
[Music]
ah what
don't tell me was the printing
that doesn't make any sense though
because
because we print every time though
so what's just the first time that we
print
that's weird
well it looks fine now
so it was the printing
are you for real
let's add the printing back in
what
what's the printing is it because it has
to initialize the console is it because
it's the first time we've printed it has
to be that
what on earth
let's print okay let's leave the
printing in but then we'll add something
random in the oncreate function like
literally
random hello
okay let's see if this has a slowdown
oh it doesn't okay oh no but it does
guys i don't know if you saw that but it
happens on instantiate now
see that was a delay
and if you don't if you can't really see
it on the stream
uh fret not because i'll record it for
you in in optic
that actually didn't didn't seem that
bad
but there it is i think is this 40
millisecond one no maybe not no here it
is 133 milliseconds on runtime start
right no no sorry that's not it either
that's the that's the actual when i hit
play in the editor uh this is probably
it create prefab entity and then this is
the create function right
no but this is the actual creating
entity part
oh because that probably runs
the oncreate function
because we didn't censor it right
but then this is projectile
on oh this is on update so it can't be
this
hmm
how interesting
but anyway
that's weird i think it is yeah i think
it's just the fact that
um
[Music]
that it's the first time that it's been
printed or something
uh anyway we shouldn't be using the
console though like in all seriousness
we shouldn't be using
this right
like at the moment what happens is we
use c sharps console.writeline
which we shouldn't be using because we
should be using something that first of
all can go into this log that we have
here
right because this log um
like you know no one's gonna be in the
grand scheme of things no one's gonna be
running
running um this side by side right this
is just something we use like during
development the actual console so
printing in this thing should be way
faster and it should be um
we can kind of already do it and i'm
pretty sure that like
let's go to log.h because because i know
that app app messages from c plus plus
show up there right so a good example is
if i click we still have a an
intersection being printed here so it
actually will print what the ray when
you do the ray picking
like what entities it intersects right
so you can see that if i position it
like here or whatever and i'll intersect
a bunch then it'll intersect two things
or like
three things or whatever
right um so those intersections uh they
get printed from c plus plus code which
by the way it's a good candidate to
remove them
um
actually let's remove them now because
otherwise i'll never remove them
so this happens here and it's called
intersection
here it is hz1 because it's an h said
one and not a core one it gets printed
in the app
client kind of side of things and that's
also why it appears in here
um because that's the way this console
works so that means though that if we go
back to the log
file class uh then
we can see how that even happens um so
we can you can see we have so editor
console logging macros
but how does that get there right
because
so hazel log get editor console logo so
okay so that's just a console logger
and i guess um
so that's also a speed log logger
and then i guess
this kind of gets connected to the app
one
at some point
editor console syncs
yeah so appsyncs you can see they they
don't just go into the app file and also
stand it out it also gets put into
editor console sync what's that one
thing here
the console sync so that's a all right
okay yeah so peter actually wrote all of
this
um so it's the first time i'm actually
looking through this card
uh but okay it seems pretty standard um
so editor console panel push message is
what happens but we need to format it
and do all this stuff to it so i think
that um at the end of the day
it's just a said console log these these
functions just need to be able to be
called from
from c sharp land so so the the question
is
how do we like what do we want to do how
do we want to make how do we want to
write these right so if we want to log
something like uh this force what do we
do
um should it be like i guess it should
be like log one whoa don't tell me
peter's already written this oh my
goodness me peter needs a promotion
damn
dude i was gonna like spend the next
hour on this
so we've had this all along in hazel and
i haven't even known so what if i just
do this for example let's just do like
um
info
holy smokes i'm actually like shook
what
how have i not been aware of this
holy
guacamole
yeah well there you go i mean it also
prints it here but notice how i think
it's faster
no well there is a bit of a pause and
again i think that's just the console to
blame but i'm sure what you could
probably do um
is that at the moment right these
loggers actually do show up in the like
it it does it it targets both but what i
think should probably happen
is um
the editor console shouldn't do this
right and if you don't add this to it
then it won't do it
so let's let's comment this out just for
fun
and now what's going to happen is
anything that we write in c sharp isn't
actually going to appear in this log now
in the grand scheme of things i don't
think i want that because
um it is nice
to have it maybe maybe to a file would
be better actually to a file
right
um oh no
uh
okay that that should be okay
they've got the same pattern anyway
um let's do this instead of this code
so that we can do as many as they as as
exist
hmm
[Music]
yeah super interesting um
this whole like slow situation
i wonder why
like i mean i i
um that wasn't particularly fast either
okay well let's um and does that happen
yeah that does
well
there is a bit of a pause
versus no pause that's the thing that's
interesting to me right there is no
pause the second time
why is that the case right
all right where are we big frames that
is the uh runtime start i keep including
that accidentally that's nothing uh
maybe that is something
okay so this still is
but projectile what on update so there's
still there still is something inside on
update that's taking all of this time
right is so this part we presume is the
log well but we can kind of tell right
because it's it's we do one single
instantiation here it takes point one
millisecond right this is us
instantiating a single entity that's
this line here
then
right and and remember like obviously
this isn't like we do more than one of
these instantiate but this is the first
one we're doing ten we're creating ten
new entities
when there's a collision right
so
that's the first one and then this is
the remaining like nine
and they take varying times this one
takes almost point one this one takes
point zero one like they take they're
actually faster than that first one but
the point is between the first one and
the second one there's like 50
milliseconds
right
so
that means that
the only other code that is between the
two
is this
and yes suspiciously log.info is in fact
there
right but then now that's our function
so we can actually profile that if we
want
but the other thing it could be again is
this add force which logically you you
might think maybe that is a bit yeah yes
vector three destructs um
but like no yes it's def it's definitely
not like heap allocation or anything
that's causing the issue here i don't
think um we are generating random
numbers
again not really though i don't really
think that's the problem and we do have
add force i want to add so add force i
want to i want to basically pro i want
to instrument log info and all the log
functions and also add force i probably
won't keep the instrumentation inside
this because it's useless but add force
i guess maybe you know that's worth
instrumenting so add force i don't even
know what that calls in c plus plus land
so let's take a look so if we go to the
script wrappers
we can take a look at the add force
function rigid body add force that
sounds like that's it
none of these by the way are
instrumented but that's okay because
they're mostly just
retrieving stuff and then we have add
force in the actor
so this stuff i do wanna um
h said uh
is it this
i think it is that i think it's just not
included
yeah it is that so let's include the
profiler
and like the thing is with the
instrumentation like you want to be kind
of careful because you get to a point
where there's just if you're if you're
instrumenting functions that do get
called a billion times per frame then
you're just gonna have too much data
it's gonna be slow it's gonna be hard to
deal with right so this is definitely
something that you wanna be careful with
um so i'm not just adding it everywhere
but like add force i feel like you know
and i might remove it if i see that it's
like
nanoseconds then whatever you know but
if it's something that actually takes
time i might keep it um so let's restart
this
um oh you know and log log as well so
log okay so what happens with the log
right so let's let's take a look because
again peter wrote this so i actually
have no idea what happens with it
um but if we if we open up the log dot
cs file
then log message native is what happens
right so that means that if we go back
to here
we look at the script wrap as we look at
log message native which doesn't exist
and how are you joking
oh no sorry it's just called log message
we don't use the word native in their
native code okay so this just does h
said console log trace okay so what we
can do is actually add um
just into here will be enough to see if
it is logging or not
if we add our profiler which i guess
just hasn't even been added um
let's go ahead and do hsn
profile funk here
right um
and then uh
[Music]
i don't trust that called monash
training to utf-8
but like again like the thing that the
thing the the thing that you have to
remember with this particular
performance thing that we're diagnosing
is the fact that it only happens the
first time so if the messages are unique
every time right because they can they
contain random values they literally
contain randomly generated numbers these
strings so it's definitely like
um you know it could still be that it
could still be like some buffer that's
pre-allocated and then reused or
something like that that
so there's like a performance penalty
the first time we call it and again this
isn't a huge deal like i don't want to i
want to emphasize the fact that this
happens during debugging and logging
stuff to the console like this is very
non like distribution build
material
um but it's still something that i'm
interested in uh pursuing for like the
next five minutes probably
so let's so we've got the log function
we've got the physics add force function
now let's take a look and see
uh what's up
so
uh what am i doing again this this is
what i'm doing
okay uh let's hit play first this time
so that we don't get the noise
play
again
sometimes you have to hit it twice
we shot we stop and
we didn't need to stop but yeah we'll
stop that i just get confused because
it's like a bunch of stop buttons okay
this is probably it right
it's not nothing is here
is it a c-sharp like memory allocation
cost or something
because look it's it's not here
instantiate is here
but then
like what takes so long here
and there's the log message .022
milliseconds right and again i think
we've we've fixed the first one right
um
we fixed the first
uh like as in we used to have like this
is not being
this is not being uh logged to the
actual console anymore right
so this is just this is just being
effectively added to a
vector or a buffer of source which
eventually im gui will render in this
kind of uh
like a log over here so so at the time
of calling the log function there should
be nothing in terms of like oh it's
printing to the console and flushing
stuff and synchronizing or between
threads or whatever
so it shouldn't be doing that anymore so
again what we're back to this issue of
what is going on
i'm beginning to think this is this is
in fact in c sharp land and instantiate
again is very fast
right so we we um we do the instantiate
function
and it's happy with it so we know that
we've progressed past this line so the
next is just basically this
because like the logging happens later
i am beginning to think that it's
something to do with the random
class
and this is temporary this is just what
is random this is yeah this is a system
random from c sharp
i don't know if that has like some kind
of uh like maybe it needs a seed or
it does something here but it shouldn't
the constructor should do that right
and the constructor happens before any
instantiation
isn't this strange okay well
shouldn't it be allocation of random by
instance in c-sharp allocation of random
well this happens before this right and
this instantiate function is what uh
this is
this is instantiate right so we're we're
not interested in this so much as this
this empty space here before the next
well before log message and there's add
force by the way point zero zero four
milliseconds so between log message so
the only thing that we have left guys
the only thing we have left
is
this
it's just these two lines
and again like so new vector three like
vector three is a struct
um we have a struct we're creating a
struct no issues should be no issues
there whatsoever
randomness double is the only culprit i
can think of unless our our profiling
data is strong
does c sharp guarantee that new random
is before instantiate um that's a good
question
this is in release mode so it is in fact
possible that maybe it has done some
stuff here's another thing we could do
right so we could move random to happen
uh on create
but again oncreate
uh and again i know that this is like
not perfect this like design of how i'm
using random numbers but this is a
little simple script guys like you know
it's not um so we could try doing this
right it will perhaps create a pause in
the oncreate function this could be
static it could be somewhere else
whatever um but let's just see what we
can do with this right
um
let's try and build that so so in this
case it definitely shouldn't happen at
any point right
um
[Music]
uh yeah yeah so my next my next step is
going to be to change the random number
to
not random number and see if that's the
case but
let's see
okay yes we still get the pause okay
we still have the pause it's it's a lot
smaller than it used to be
but it's still there and
i just can't handle it so
what was that let's do that again that
was weird
maybe we still got it but i want to do
it again
ah it's because i didn't um hit escape
last time
play
shoot
stop
stop
okay so where are we where are we at
there it is 59 well i mean 59
milliseconds is a lot better than 200
something but yeah so it's still same
situation
um by the way the create function
uh do we know when the create function
happens
no oh what's this
oh
okay look guys so this is it
this instantiate function that's what
creates the projectile so the projectile
really only lasted for 15 frames right
so when we shot
that was this right that's actually that
took a decent amount of time for some
reason create prefab entity that took
like seven milliseconds why is that so
slow that whole update took 12. that's
that's significant
maybe we should investigate that as well
because i'm pretty sure
subsequent firings don't
take that much time
um but anyway uh but yeah again 55
milliseconds for this one
[Music]
also get one random number in oncreate
could do that
okay let's try that and then after that
and i'll probably have to like print it
because it'll it's in a release it might
optimize it out so let's just do that
um
oh
i think that may have
fixed it yeah
so it is the random number generator
because look now when i fire i think
there's a bit of a pause but there's not
a pause when i um
when i collide anymore so let's try that
like uh if i try that i mean profile
that so let's hit play
we'll fire
it stop
i always keep getting stopped there um
but yeah let's see that okay so look at
that so we have a 62 millisecond delay
now but look it's in the create prefab
entity in the instantiate from fps
player so fps player is the player
controller script that when you click it
spawns that cube so it's the random
number generator
and it's specifically i guess the first
time you call
next double
right so the first time that you call
next double
it freaks out
so
now c sharp source code is on the
internet isn't it
uh so like dot net framework source code
i'm pretty sure it's up there right it's
on github it's open source on github so
let's see for fun just to wrap this up
nicely and neatly
let's see if we can find this
so system
and
that system maybe
no i've ruined everything
okay let's just let's just search for it
can i just start typing how do i search
again
random.cs
just googling the file
i found it
aha okay i don't know what version this
is from or whatever but
i'm assuming that next double has some
kind of
ah let's call it jumps to this
sample internal sample
um i mean it doesn't look like it does
any kind of like special stuff on the
first time you call it
right
next double that's definitely what i was
using right
yeah random next double i yeah again i
don't even know what version that's from
it's reference source it seems like it
should be fine though like it should be
what we're using
yeah so they kind of all call sample at
the end of the day
and then that calls internal sample
which is this function here
which
seed array
just an array of 56
yeah so so this definitely like when you
when you hit random right
um it calls this with environment tick
count which i guess is some kind of
internal clock
so it calls this other constructor with
a seed that is just like the current
time and then this obviously does do
some initialization in the constructor
that's what it seems to do right
again
not really seeing anything here that
would take 50 milliseconds
right but it is uh
i mean like these for loops are like 55
and they're just some math so like
don't really see anything major
but
like sam internal sample seems even
internal sample does nothing right look
at what it's doing
it's doing nothing it's doing some
arithmetic like not much arithmetic
either
i'm very overexposed
i just checked
the camera
um but anyway what
how interesting
doesn't have framework 4.8 now i'm not
using 4.8 though i think i'm using 4.7
let's just check um i think it's 4.7.2
from memory
4.7.2 see how good am i i know my own
engine 4.7.2 so
uh can i switch to that doesn't look
like it
what if they completely chose to rewrite
it
nah i don't think they have that
but like if it's on github why
why
why is it why could i not find it here
oh this is years ago actually
but look four eight is here not framing
four eight they only do they only keep
the
they're probably like.net core and stuff
now right
but yeah i'm shocked that i couldn't
find random.cs
is it because
[Music]
oh my gosh it's because i typed in okay
so in github if you type in random.cs it
can't find anything because it doesn't
include file names in its search it only
searches through code
so it was always here here it is
oh 4.6 okay this is an older version but
again it looks identical i don't know
why they would suddenly decide oh yeah
let's rewrite the whole random class and
make it slow but like
weird
i don't know um
[Music]
it i i don't know
okay people are linking helpful stuff
maybe
avoiding multiple instantiations don't
know framework initializing two random
number generators in tight loop or not
yet that was never happening never ever
was that happening there was no
what i was doing before
right before i moved it up because again
now i'm not doing anything i'm creating
it and then i'm doing next double and
then that's this these two lines of code
and specifically this code is taking 50
milliseconds now i am i am also logging
it but that i don't think it's the
logging that's ma what if it's logging
but we we tested it without logging
right and it was still slow was it
but again no no okay yeah sorry it can't
be the logging because we profiled it
and we did log in for and we know that
the slowness was between instantiate and
log info
so we know that it was this
so yes so we did do that um and again
remember guys logging in this case
anymore is not logging into the console
it's logging to
it's logging into a vector essentially
that is then let it be displayed in the
ui so it's not actually like console
logging
um
but yeah what i was doing before though
was here right
i was doing this sorry not entity i was
doing this right and so this means this
is an on update if destroyed right so if
we have a collision we destroy just that
way because we can't um we can't like uh
we can't instantiate new physics bodies
inside a collision inside a collision
callback so we um
[Music]
uh defer it to the next update and then
we destroy this current entity as well
so this does not get another update
after this so this code even though it's
in on update runs once only once per
green cube that we shoot
not per like orange ball that we
that is our that is our explosion a lot
of a lot of stuff
going on man
a lot of stuff going on
anyway so
that's being said
if you now you're only creating random
instances but not using it so if it lags
on shot it means no no so it's not like
um
this does not lag anymore now what's
like there is no lag so what i did is i
added this line here
right to make sure that we actually
generate at least one random number
using this
and there is now a delay here
if i remove this so the first time we
call random next double is inside here
it's the
it's this code that lags
that like takes 50 milliseconds the
first time
so we know that it is it seems to be
random next double now another thing we
could do is like c sharp has some timers
right we could just see sharp time of
this right that would probably be very
simple um and that'll probably be the
best solution i think for the just to
like make sure that's actually that so
like c sharp timer um
there's just a timer class we can just
do sell like is this a good performance
timer i don't know if it's good for
performance but
ah whatever
okay so let's do um
uh timer timer
this is some threading system threading
timer system threading
all right okay so the same thing
so let's try this
i don't even know if this is like a good
timer with an infinite period and an
infinite due time using uh oh wait
that's probably not what i want
uh
maybe i should go c sharp performance
timer
it's been a while since i've uh done
that
try not logging the next result to the
next table yeah i'm i'm gonna do it
outside of logging don't you worry oh
yeah stopwatch sorry that's it in system
diagnostics yes
stop watch
give me that
and let's get rid of threading well
actually we don't need like anything
here
stopwatch
and does that start immediately
apparently you can do
start new
uh and then we can do
dot stop
stop w dot elapsed milliseconds and
we'll log that in our
uh
well we'll log that actually into the
console how about that
stopwatch
okay let's do that not the best uh but
like again and i've left the log in
there for now but that's just
temporarily right
um should we maybe make this a bit
smaller ah
i'm exposed
all right um
so let's uh i hate it when windows does
that by the way i need to turn that off
um so
uh let's i don't know why i'm still
printing this stuff
um let's hit play
okay that should have already done it
oh no sorry it's when we when we shoot
on exception beautiful guys we did it
why oh no what
[Music]
you're really gonna give me an exception
be nice if we knew which exception but
of course i'm uh
i only care if it's a null reference
exception um
so we got this right
if exception doesn't equal not yeah
let's let's maybe like um
actually write what exception it is that
would be useful
let's do that
but we don't know what it is well it's
exception it's probably got this stuff
right oh but
okay um
uh
well it has to be an exception surely
it has to be the base class right
look i'm being all c sharpie here
instead of using cast operators
aren't you guys proud of me
all of ea's tools are pretty much
written in c sharp by the way so i do
have quite a bit of c sharp experience
um from like my ea days
um all right so
um
[Music]
so let's uh let's just hit play and see
what the exception is
could not load us
what